hello everyone and welcome to a
thrilling and very enjoyable game from
round three of the uh video grand prix
2022 we are currently being played in
berlin it's levon arun vs vincent keimer
and i attended two children birthdays
today uh so i didn't really follow what
was happening in the chess world and i
got uh home now and i've i i can see
that we're pretty much spoiled for
choice regarding the the games we can
analyze so this is the one that i'm
starting with it's super enjoyable you
guys will uh very much like it uh but
i'm also taking suggestions for the next
one i show as i will show at least one
more from round three so without further
ado let's check it out uh it's uh
a very nice game so levon with the white
pieces opens with e4 we have c6 camera
goes for the karo khan defense we have
d4 d5 and levon goes for the exchange
variation we have e captures c captures
and bishop to d3 so
very very solid
knight to f3 we have h3 now taking away
the g4 square from black's pieces and
knight to c6 we have knight to f3 and
now knight to b4 so kind of breaking the
opening principle even though it's hard
to say if that's even a thing anymore
with all of the uh neural nets and and
very strong engines that are suggesting
us uh suggesting to us what to play uh
but um yeah all in all whenever i see
such a move i um you know
at least uh frown upon it so here now
okay we're threatening to pick up
white's a light square bishop and we
we're gonna win the bishop pair however
you are neglecting your development so
let's see how lavon deals with this he
just continues developing knight to c3
and now we have g6 so there are a couple
of games where knight captures and d3
was played but here we have g6 and now
it is already as of move seven that we
have a completely new game as that's uh
and information you guys very much enjoy
so knight to e5 the e5 square has been
uh made available as the knight left the
c6 square so you don't have to worry
about losing the d4 pawn or your knight
being threatened in any way and it's a
an incredible square for the knight so
here a6 by camera we have castles and
bishop to g7 black is now also ready to
castle rook to e1 and vincent castles
and now bishop to g5 so putting a lot of
pressure on that e7 square
and here knight captures on d3 finally
the knight picks up the the bishop we
have c captures the queen could capture
but then you allow black to develop with
tempo so we're going to capture with the
c pawn and now uh yes we have a double
the deep one but we are controlling a
lot of central squares here for example
this knight will never be able to go to
e4 and that's a usually a good square
for this knight so here queen to b6
attacking the d4 pawn and the b2 pawn
and levon defends it very elegantly with
knight to f3
so the d4 pawn is now defended uh and
the b2 pawn is a poison pawn uh if you
capture on b2 we're going to play knight
a4 attack your queen and also your e7
pawn is now hanging so if queen a3
defending and attacking on a4 we're
going to play knight to b6 attack the
rook and now you can't go rogue ba
because bishop f4 so you have to play
rook a7 and already you can see that
black is not really enjoying this
position rook to b1 can be played and
after some like bishop to f5 if you go
after the d3 pawn we can even play g4
and white is just much better here of
course the pawn can never be captured if
you play the bishop captures on d3 rook
b3 and the black is lost here so instead
after this knight to f3 move with e6
vincent continues developing now
strengthens the pawn chain and knight
the a for now saying that's a weird
square for the queen i get a nice tempo
for bringing my knight to c5 so queen to
d6 and now uh queen to d2
developing the queen connecting the
rooks uh we have a5 now stopping uh any
rapid uh the development here on the
queen side like b4
and rook a to c1 also black might have
some ideas of maybe queen to b4 trying
to trade off queens but first rook a to
c1 and now if you try something like
this queen to b4 we can even just
capture it just captures captures and
this is uh well this is lost for uh for
black because after
knight to b6 uh what do you play the
bishop is attacked twice and also the
rook is hanging if you go rook to b8 uh
for example rook to b8 we're going to
play rook to c7 or even knight to e5 and
this is uh a terrible terrible position
though we're going to bring our rook to
c1 and there's no way for black to hold
this so instead we have bishop to d7
putting pressure on the knight here
developing the bishop connecting rooks
and now knight to c5 so attacking that
b7 pawn and now probably best for black
is just bishop to c6 but vincent plays
b6 he wants to chase away the knight and
now comes the ship to f4
also a an upside of having your queen on
d2 you control the d for the f4 square
so you can play bishop to f4
queen to e7 and now knight captures on
d7 and now you can see that levon won
the c file he's going to bring the rook
to c7 and it's going to be very very
difficult to kick it away from there so
knight captures or queen capture doesn't
really matter uh rook the c7 is what we
play we have rook f the c8 challenging
the rook and now rook e to c1 now
threatening to pick up the rook here so
queen to d8 defending and attacking on
c7 but the the c7 rook is sufficiently
defended so now we just bring more
firepower and play a queen to c2 now
we're threatening rook captures on c8
again so rook captures queen captures we
have queen captures and the rook
captures so this is what levon got out
of the position he won the c file and
having the rook on the seventh is
incredibly dangerous as you know the
rook on the seventh is called a pig
because it can just gobble up all of the
pawns and it's very hard to stop it so
rook to d8 we're defending the knight
and now rook to b7 paralyzing the knight
or the b6 spawn i will follow if the
knight moves so what can you play here
well came to a f8 we have to start by
something so we're going to activate our
king bishop the d6 check we have king
the e8 and now knight to e5 and uh again
levon has an incredibly firm grip on the
position it's hard to even make a move
for black and imagine if this knight
ever comes to c7 that's checkmate so
it's uh it's maybe best to just uh
remove the knight from the board so
bishop captures an e5
uh we have d captures on e5 and now rook
the c8 again if you're thinking let's
play something like knight to c5 let's
activate our pieces attack the d3 pawn
this is very difficult to play because
first you have to give up the pawn
rookie 7 check you have to go under the
mask of the bishop we're going to pick
up the pawn with check and now after the
king moves king j8 we're going to bring
the rook back and now we have a very
dangerous pawn here and already okay you
can capture on d3 but now bishop c7 goes
after the b6 pawn rook the c8 we're
going to capture on b6 knight captures
on b2 even bishop captures an a5 and now
we have this position where levon would
have the outside past a pawn and vincent
would have the past d-pawn but still
white is uh white is definitely to be
preferred here and even if you try rook
to a8 which seems like it picks up the
a2 pawn not really bishop c3 and now if
you capture the pawn there's even the
deadly rook eight check king g7 and e6
check giving levon an even greater pass
pawn so f6 blocking check let's say
rookie seven checking to federal
captures on h7 and this is game over for
for black
so uh
while this is a very good move uh it's
uh not easy to find useful moves after
that so rook the c8 sorry that's not a
c8 rook the c8 is what vincent plays he
wants to at least activate the rook but
it's
definitely easier said than done yeah so
here we have uh
d4 by levon and now king to d8 we have
rook to a7 as the b8 square is not
available the knight defends this so if
the rook ever moves from the back rank
you can play rook to a8 to check and
that's pretty much a game
uh so rook to c4 and okay now you can
play rook to a8 but we can bring the
rook back with rook to c8 so first level
wants to force the rook to move from the
c file so b3 now of course if you
capture here and just rotate check we
can even show it and you lose the knight
the king cannot move from the bishop so
knight has to be
given away and that's it white wins so
instead after b3 rook the c1 check we
have kinked the h2 and now h6 making
some pawn moves but uh fact of the
matter is black is uh
totally out of any useful moves here so
king g3 rook the c3 check now f3 and now
rook to c6 and now vincent just has to
wait and see what levon will come up
with so h4
we have rooked rogue back to c8 now
comes h5 and now rook to c6 it doesn't
matter if you play g5 we're still gonna
break open the position with f4 so king
h4 now comes rook back to c8 vincent has
to repeat moves now comes g4 uh king to
e8 again if g5 now you can even kick
away the king we're still gonna play f4
and bust open the position get it past h
pawn and win the game so after g4 we
have king to e8 again waiting to see
what happens we have f4 king to d8 and
now h captures on g6
f captures on g6 and g5 and now black
finally gets a moment to catch his
breath he plays h5 and it seems like uh
all the pushing uh has stopped but that
could not be further from the truth uh
so feel free to pause the video here and
try to find the the quickest way to win
this with white while i give you a
couple of seconds
so for those of you who are able to do
it congratulations on spotting any of
the winning moves and yes b4 is also
winning in this position like in many
others but the quickest way to win is
what levon played that is f5 so
congratulations to everyone who found
this and it was in this position on 42
that vincent keimer resigned the game as
there is nothing more to be done here uh
problem is even though the f5 square is
defended twice by black pawns uh well
let's try capturing with the e pawn
we're just gonna play e6
chase away the knight and once the
knight moves wherever it doesn't really
matter just e7 check the pawn is
defended and after king moves e captures
an f8 with uh bringing a queen into the
game or even the rook this is all
checkmate and another thing after f5
even if g captures we just push the g
pawn and now after king e8 we can try
and stop the pawn even g7 right away
because there's no way to stop the pawn
you can play king f7 but then you give
up the knight with check the pawn is
defended and again black is completely
lost so really an impressive game uh
levon took an opening that's uh
considered not all that much for white
it's uh basically a quick exchange
you know
right out of the opening on move three
playing bishop to d3 so this is all
very standard this is uh something tal
would say that uh it would be a crime
against chess to play uh to play chess
like this uh but you can see that with
the brilliant positional play you can
still uh get uh
a lot of ideas and the levon is a
brilliant positional player when he has
a good day uh he just uh
obliterates every everyone uh so yeah
after this f5 move winston resigned and
another brilliant victory for lavon uh
who is now leading his group he's up a
full point but we're gonna check out a
few more games and then we're gonna
discuss the standings of all the groups
and what's been happening
uh so yeah uh that's the game hope you
guys enjoyed it another uh brilliancy by
lavonne i would like to wish a very
happy birthday to theo and i would like
to thank triple triangle daniel
silverberg john black and patrick
mulcair for your contribution to my
channel thank you a lot i really
appreciate it as usual you can check to
my previous videos here thank you for
watching and i will see you soon
continuing the coverage of this
spectacular event
while uh
you know
yeah
uh until it ends yeah
so yeah
thank you all i will see you soon and
have an excellent rest of your day